this little thing is is absolutely to
die for so I'm just it's been a month
since Prince Harry and Megan Markel
introduced us to then 48 hour old baby
Archie now we're breaking down all the
ways their lives have changed since
becoming parents magic I had the two
best guys in the world
for starters mmm has been noticeably
absent from the public eye
tripping the colors on June 7th was her
first appearance in a month I'm told it
was really important to Megan it was her
way of paying her respects to Her
Majesty the Queen and check out that new
bling on her ring finger beneath her
engagement ring and her wedding band is
a new eternity ring it was a first
anniversary present harry's very
romantic when it comes to gifts he's
he's very generous and this was a very
special very sentimental present from
him to his wife to celebrate that very
first important first anniversary okay
were swooning
now obviously the Duchess has been m.i.a
because she's on maternity leave and
from the sounds of it she won't be
making appearances anytime soon my
palace sources tell me not to expect
Megan to return to work full-time until
the fall when we're expecting the couple
to undertake a tour of South Africa a
source tells et that Megan and Harry
have been nesting enjoying their first
month as mummy and daddy
it's been about three weeks now since
Doria returned to LA and up until that
point they really were just managing as
a threesome with the help of Megan's
mother Harry has been changing nappies
Megan's been up in the night she's
nursing so feeding on demands really
every few hours of her knee he's a
hungry little baby but mama needs some
help given that her hubby had one of the
shortest paternity leaves in royal
history and we're now learning that
they've finally hired a nanny there was
a lot of speculation that they were
going to hire a male nanny but yes they
have hired a nanny and no details as to
who that is apparently they've signed a
very strict NDA now as you well know
Megan was the fitness Queen prior to
giving birth she even turned Harry into
somewhat of a health fiend but after
having Archie the new mom is reportedly
cutting herself some slack at least for
now I'm told that she's been following
something called the fourth trimester
which is a pretty holistic approach to
those first four weeks after the baby's
birth Megan hasn't been hitting the gym
she hasn't
hurry to get back into shape when her
mother was over here they were
practicing yoga together and lots of
pram walks around wins the Great Park so
gentle exercise and but no hard training
no weights in luckily mmm seems to have
all the support from friends and family
a royal source tells ET that the Sussex
is have been entertaining their loved
ones who have in turn showered them with
gifts their very pleasing glance
welcomed a brother to the deprivation
society parenting the best part is baby
our cheese seems to have helped patch up
the rift between the Fab Four
William is over the moon that his
brother is is a dad Kate is very broody
she loves to be around newborns and I
hear that caters made herself available
to Megan if she needs advice but she
needs any help as for a royal
christening there aren't any details
released as of yet there's some
speculation that the christening will
happen in the early part of July before
the Queen goes on holiday to Balmoral I
don't think it's going to be a huge
affair despite turning to but tradition
we're told the new parents will most
likely follow protocol on this one it's
very likely that we will see Archie
christened at Windsor at San George's
Chapel well we're looking forward to
catching another glimpse of mr. Archie
Harrison since all we've gotten since
our first introduction was this sweet
pic of his little Tootsie's Megan posted
on Mother's Day they celebrated a
Megan's first Mother's Day and quietly
in in the grounds of frock Lords and
we're told the trio is likely to
celebrate Harry's first Father's Day in
a similar way this is gonna be a really
important day for Prince Harry he waited
for a very long time to become a father
therefore there were moments when he
feared he never would become a dad so to
mark Father's Day with baby Archie is
going to be really special we're loving
are these firsts and can't wait for more
[Music]